s'il y a bien un produit qu'il faut
avoir à la maison c'est un aspirateur
robot parce qu'il rend énormément de
service et il vous permet de venir
nettoyer ce qui globalement n'est pas
une passion je n'aime pas à faire le
ménage à la maison j'imagine que vous
aussi si vous regardez cette vidéo et
bien justement il y a dream me qui
arrive avec un tout nouveau produit dont
le nom est extrêmement à ralonge
regardez j'ai le carton qui est juste là
c'est écrit dreamy bot l10s pro ultra
hit et ouais ils ont de l'imagination
chez dreamis aiment bien faire des noms
un petit peu longs mais c'est pas grave
parce que cet aspirateur il est cool il
fait plein de jolies choses il a plein
de tech extrêmement innovante et c'est
vraiment ce qui nous intéresse al la
première chose que je vais vous montrer
c'est le robot il y a rien de plus qu'un
robot aspirateur qui ressemble à un
robot aspirateur sauf que le diable se
cache dans les détails et le détail on
va le retrouver notamment ici au niveau
des serpillères alors déjà pour
reprendre un peu l'histoire ceux qui
sauraient pas et bien votre aspirateur
il va venir se balader comme ça regardez
là il y a marqué ai action il y a
l'intelligence artificielle il a une
caméra il a des capteurs de tous les
côtés il va venir toucher lorsqu'il
avance voyez tac il touche un obstacle
tac ça enfon ça il se décale il avance
il se reconnaît tout au début en plus il
est vachement malin il venir
cartographier votre maison comme ça il
aura un plan de votre maison je vous
montre ça dans l'application dans
quelques instants il saura exactement où
aller vous pourrez l'envoyer dans une
zone en particulier bref c'est très
pratique donc il a ses capteurs il
avance et puis en dessous il y a plein
de techno qui sont cool à savoir que lui
il va venir tourner comme ça donc toutes
les petites cochoneries qui va trouver
il va les ramener ici ensuite vous avez
une brosse avec du caotchou qui avec
toute l'aspiration katsous et bien vient
tout ramener à l'intérieur alors
regardez je vous montre ça peut venir se
déboîter comme ça comme ça si vous la
nettoyer il y a aucun problème c'est
très très très très facile donc là ça
aspire c'est pratique c'est mignon c'est
sympa et ça ça me plaît ça se met dans
ce sensl monsieur gros c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux voilà ça vient devant et
surtout moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
partie que vous avez arère ça ce sont
des serpillères oui absolument
serpillères qui vont venir tourner pour
venir laver directement vos sols alors
ça vous me direz c'est bien c'est mignon
il y en a plein qui le font mais
celle-là c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est-à-dire que vous avez la
technologie qui s'appelle mop extend çaà
dire ça va venir décaler votre
serpilletre regardez prenez tac hop là
je l'enlève vous allez voir qu'ici et
ouais on l' remarqué ça va pas décaler
grandchose mais ici ça va venir décaler
pourquoi bien parce que cette partie là
va venir ici et en fait ça fait quoi ça
fait que ça ça va venir juste là alors
ça va pas venir frotter soyez tranquille
par contre ça vient vraiment nettoyer à
rat et le truc qui est vraiment génial
avec ça c'est que ça vient nettoyer le
long des plaines c'est par exemple
j'imagine vous avez une chaise une table
pied de bureau et compagnie et bien ça
vient vraiment nettoyer le long de vos
meubles pour venir ramasser toutes les
cochonneries partout le long des
escaliers le long des marches dans les
coins irréguliers bref vous êtes
vraiment tranquille et cette techno elle
est super cool parce que avant parce que
vous n'aviez pas cette techno mob exttin
installé et oui on l'a entendu et bien
ça venait comme ça et là vous avez une
petite zone voyez qui restait où ça
venait pas le faire alors ça que
l'aspirateur se décalait comme ça et
comme ça mais là c'est quand même
vachement mieux et en terme de nettoyage
vous aurez un nettoyage qui sera
beaucoup mieux fait dans les coins que
ce qu'on pouvait faire avant ça c'est le
premier point qui est très très cool
votre aspirateur est ici dans cette base
alors il vient se poser juste en bas
comme ça il se recharge il est peénard
alors vous allez voir parce qu'en fait
lorsqu'il recule il vient se vider
directement en cochonnerie là il vient
se recharger directement en eau chaud en
eau froide et ensuite il vient nettoyer
ses spillères directement ici à l'eau
chaude bon ça je vous en parle dans
quelques instants ensuite il vient se
positionner directement tranquille là
lui-même normalement c'est pas vous qui
le faites ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à venir connaître c'est que
lorsque vous levez le capot ici vous
allez avoir deux bacs vous allez avoir
un bac d'eau propre dans lequel vous
allez retrouver votre eau que vous allez
mettre directement bon voyez c'est l'au
propre vous êtes tranquille vous allez
avoir ensuite un bac d'eau sale qui va
être juste là et qui va venir récupérer
et bien les EOS usagés qu'il a venu
nettoyer donc les EOS sales remontent
directement là mais alors le truc qui
est cool c'est que juste là et bien vous
allez avoir deux parties intéressantes
alors ça on connaissait déjà ça c'est le
sac avec toutes les les impuretés le sac
à déchet qui est juste là qui fait 3,2 l
comme ça vous pouvez en mettre alors oui
pour info le réservoir d'eau propre
c'est 4,5 L et le réservoir d'eau sale
c'est 4 l bon franchement vous avez de
quoi faire mais vous avez juste là un
petit truc qui me plaît et qui
m'intéresse vachement puisque dreamy
vous fournit une solution de détergent
et bien regardez ce que vous faites
c'est que vous venez le mettre
directement ici donc là voyez il me
reste du détergent à l'intérieur ensuite
je viens le positionner directement
comme ça juste là et puis une fois que
tout est en place je n'ai plus qu'à
remettre le capot qui est aimanté qui
trouve sa place très facilement alors
ici la serpillère sera lavée à l'eau
chaude ça c'est quand même vachement
bien et puis surtout le truc qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'il existe un quit
de raccordement parce que ici j'ai deux
réservoir réservoir d'eau sale réservoir
d'eau propre je peux si je souhaite et
bien venir le brancher directement sur
le tout àé goû et me brancher sur un
robinet alors il y a une petite
installation à faire il y a un kit à
venir acheter en plus mais si j'ai
vraiment envie de pas m'embêter et de ne
pas venir toucher à un bac d'eau propre
ou un bac d'au sale et bien je peuxenir
faire le raccordement bon c'est en plus
en tout cas ça le mérite d'exister et
puis le truc qui est pas mal aussi c'est
que vous avez une recharge qui va être
30 % plus rapide que la génération
précédente intéressant cet aspirateur
est bien évidemment livré avec quelques
petits accessoires et ça c'est plutôt
bien alors déjà on va voir ça ça c'est
la solution de nettoyage qui va être
livrée directement avec votre aspirateur
alors comme vous l'avez vu sur la base
et bien en fait vous venez mettre votre
produit directement à l'intérieur là où
sur certains autres aSPIRATEURS ROBOT
vous laissez la solution nettoyage à
l'intérieur ce qui est bien c'est que ça
permet soit de mettre le produit Dream
me soit de mettre vous-même votre propre
détergent ça vous laisse le choix et je
trouve ça quand même pas mal autre
accessoire c'est la petite brossette
pour bien nettoyer votre aspirateur si
vous le souhaitez regardez il est là oh
là là là là qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
a eu des petites cochonneries voà vous
venez nettoyer très facilement autre
truc qui est très cool c'est que vous
allez avoir voir ici de quoi couper les
petits cheveux donc là si vous avetz des
petits cheveux qui sont coincés dans les
roues les patins et compagnie et bien
clac vous y mettez un coup vous les
enlevez vous êtes peinard donc là on a
de la polyvalence au niveau de cet
accessoire une fois de plus côté
nettoyage c'est pratique vous venez le
poser quelque part comme ça regardez
vous êtes peénard vous avez également un
autre sac avec sac d'aspiration qui est
livré avec et ça c'est quand même un
point qui est aussi extrêmement positif
vous l'avez vu dans la base il est à
l'intérieur il vient se mettre alors
bien évidemment vous en avez un d'avance
il faudra en acheter d'autres après ça
c'est forcément obligatoire et puis vous
avez un manuel d'installation qui vous
explique venir l'installer c'est super
facile à venir installer vous prenez
votre base vous le branchez
électriquement vous posez le petit
plateau devant pour venir l'accueillir
vous mettez l'eau chaude l'eau froide
enfin les bacs vous les remplissez enfin
c'est vraiment super simple et tout est
expliqué ici on vous prend par la main
c'est plutôt bien la garantie bien
évidemment et puis ensuite la notice en
plusieurs langues soyez tranquille parce
que là c'est tellement épais que vous
direz j'ai pas y passer des heures non
plus à venir lire ce bouquin c'est en
français en partie vous êtes tranquille
donc on vous prend réellement par la
main pour venir l'installer pour
comprendre comment ça se passe et si
vous avez des questions bien évidemment
vous avez aussi plein de réponses
directement sur le site de Dream autre
sujet qui est très bien vous le voyez
ici ça vient inspirer ça vient se mettre
par là et bien ici vous avez une très
grosse puissance d'inpiration 7000
Pascal alors pas 7000 Pascal en
permanence mais 7000 Pascal c'est le
maximum ce qui va se passer c'est que
vous allez pouvoir avoir une
fonctionnalité dans l'application et je
vous le montre dans quelques instants
l'idée c'est que lorsque votre
aspirateur va arriver sur des tapis il
va venir booster muscler l'aspiration
pour bien tout aspirer donc vous montez
jusqu'à une puissance maximale de 7000
Pascal entre techno et pas des moindres
c'est une techno vous allez retrouver au
niveau de la serpillère parce que
lorsque vous nettoyez sur un sol bien
évidemment on veut que la serpilère soit
passée mais lorsque vous arrivez sur un
tapis on n pas envie que la serpilière
Vienne frotter le tapis ça sert à rien
c'est pas terrible ça vient un peu tout
abîmé on veut pas ça du coup on a une
techno qui est très cool et super
intéressante c'est une techno de
relevage de la serpillère à savoir que
et bien en fait ici ça va venir se
relever vos serpillères vont venir
remonter ce qui permettra qu'elles ne
viendront plus frotter lorsqu'elles
seront sur une zone de contact non
désiré on va parler ici dansun tapis par
exemple mais si vous voulez faire une
aspiration sans nettoyage en la
paramétrant dans l'application et je
vous montre dans un instant comment
faire et bien c'est totalement possible
et ce qui est bien c'est que vous montez
de 10,5 cm c'est très précis ce qui
permet une fois de plus à vos serpilères
de ne pas venir frotter les tapis autre
techno Genius clean qu'est-ce que ça
permet et bien ça permet que votre
aspirateur il va être intelligent il va
venir détecter les zones qui sont très
salalees pour venir faire plusieurs
nettoyages et oui il y a de Lia à
l'intérieur vous l'avez vu alors ça une
fois de plus en calibre dans
l'application je vous le montre tout à
l'heure alors vous me direz mon
aspirateur il a fait le taf les tapis il
fait bien tous les coins tout va bien ok
ça c'est bien c'est la base mais
qu'est-ce qui va se passer une fois que
mes cpillers auront fait le boulot
est-ce que je dois les enlever comme ça
venir les laver moi-même venir les
tais-toi venir les sécher et bien ce qui
va se passer en fait c'est que c'est pas
à vous de le faire l'idée d'un robot
aspirateur c'est que vous ne vous
embêtez plus ni pour le ménage ni pour
l'entretien la seule chose que vous
aurez à faire c'est à remplir le bac
d'eau propre à vider le bac Dossal sauf
si vous avez installé un système de
vidangeche mais je vous en parle dans
quelques instants et bien évidemment à
venir changer votre sac à poussière
c'est le seul truc alors si
effectivement faut rajouter un peu de
détergent c'est sûr mais au-delà de ça
vous ne touchez à rien et ce qui est
génial est ce que nous a fait ici dreamy
c'est-à-dire que ils viennent laver
directement les serpillères avec de
l'eau chaude oui c'estd que dans le bac
où il y a les serpillères venir mettre
de l'eau chaude ça va venir les frotter
les nettoyer comme ça vous aurez les
serpillères qui sont toujours propres et
alors après me direzv bon c'est bien mis
non bon monsieur Greux mais une fois que
mes serpillères ont été lavées et bien
si elle ne sèche pas il va y avoir une
dégagement d'odeur il peut y avoir des
moisissures des bactéries et c'est le
bazar c'est vrai c'est justement aussi
un truc qu' a fait à Dream ici à savoir
qu'ils viennent ensuite sécher
directement vos serpilières comme ça
vous êtes tranquille le job BF elles
sont propres elles sont sèches jusqu'à
la prochaine utilisation votre
application dreammeum vous permet de
naviguer entre vos différents
aspirateurs voyez ici j'ai un l10s ultra
je vais avoir le L20 ultra qui est hor
ligne mais que j'ai ici je vais avoir le
l106 pro ultra hit qui est juste là qui
est chargé à 93 % et là j'ai qu'à
cliquer dessus pour arriver directement
sur mon aspirateur robot alors là on
regarde j'ai un plan de ma maison je
vois la dernière fois qu'il a nettoyé 73
minutes je vois la superficie qu'il a
nettoyé et en fait j'ai accès à plein de
paramètres je vous explique là je vais
avoir toute ma zone avec mon nettoyage
je vais voir mes pièces donc je peux
l'envoyer voyer dans une pièce ou dans
l'autre si j'ai besoin je peux venir
faire également un nettoyage de zone en
lui disant ben tiens par exemple tu vas
venir ici j'ai fait tomber de la
confiture je règle ma zone vous voyez ça
me fait une petite loupe en haut c'est
quand même très pratique carreau par
carreau je l'envoie là je dis tu vas là
tac tac tac ça c'est pratique en plus je
dis les cycles tu vas me le faire une
fois deux fois trois fois ou une fois et
puis ensuite je peux dire tu m'as fait
ça mais ensuite je clique là tu vas
aller me faire ça également attention on
n'est pas là pour déconner comme ça on
définit vraiment des endroits j'en ai
mis là et puis comme je suis un gros
cochon j'en ai mis aussi par ici ouais
c'est pas terrible et si je veux pas et
ben je clique là voyez je clique là hop
là juste dessous et je viens les
supprimer donc là je peux faire un
nettoyage par zone je peux faire
également un nettoyage par pièce je v
dire ben tiens la salle à manger deux
ici tu vas venir me la nettoyer une fois
deux fois trois fois comme ça c'est
quand même très très très très pratique
voilà un peu pour le principe comme ça
je peux dire où aller ensuite je vais
avoir mes paramètres de nettoyage
nettoyage de routine nettoyage en
profondeur en fonction de ce que je veux
moi je me mets sur un nettoyage de
routine globalement ça me va bien le
mieux après c'est de venir programmer
directement mais je vous montre dans
quelques instants comment faire ensuite
je peux venir personnaliser là j'ai les
paramètres de nettoyage donc là je dis
que il peut venir soit aspirer soit la
serpilière moi je préfère aspirer irer
et serpillère comme ça il fait deux en
même temps je peux marquer également
serpillère après aspirateur comme ça tu
m'enlèves tout et ensuite tu repasses et
ensuite tu aspires et après je peux
venir personnaliser le nettoyage des
pièces où je lui dis et bien en fonction
de telle pièce tu vas venir faire
celle-là tu vas aspirer celle-là tu vas
faire si comme ça je dis pièce par pièce
ce que je veux sur la puissance
d'aspiration sur le mode de nettoyage
sur l'humidité également et sur le
nombre de cycle comme ça voyez on peut
aller extrêmement loin et vraiment venir
personnaliser son nettoyage et c'est
vraiment un point extrêmement important
et bien ensuite je vais voir les
paramètres de la station d'accueil la
vage à l'eau chaude oui non alors moi
j'ai mis oui bien évidemment lavage
automatique bien évidemment je veux
qu'on vienne laver ma serpillère
directement le robot lavera avec des
serpillères sèche qui reviendra pour
laver lorsque laage est terminé ensuite
le mode de lavage léger standard en
profondeur voyez ensuite sur le séchage
bien évidemment je du séchage je choisis
la durée du séchage 2h 3h 4h à he c'est
l' intermédiaire moi ça me va bien le
vidage également vidage automatique si
le réglage est désactivé le robot
reviendra à la station de base sans se
vider automatiquement à la fin de la
tche de nettoyage on peut mettre
standard très fréquent peu fréquent
voyez on a vra vraiment la main
directement ici sur tous les paramètres
et ça c'est quand même très très très
cool et puis après vous avez deux
boutons nettoyer retour à la station de
base là il est à côté de moi si j'appuie
sur Retour à la station de base il va se
larguer ça va pas être terrible reste là
ne bouge surtout pas donc voilà pour je
dirais les paramètres un peu de base et
ensuite alors on va voir regarder
différentes option je peux cliquer juste
là où là je peux venir afficher la carte
venir mettre des meubles si je le
souhaite également nom des pièces les
obstacles je peux faire tourner la carte
je peux également afficher la carte en
3D je peux venir bien évidemment éditer
ma carte la renommer sauvegarder
restaurer supprimer je peux mettre des
cloisons je peux mettre également des
condition ou du terrain pour dire quel
genre de de de zone c'est par exemple
ici bien voyez au niveau du matériaux
que c'était des carreaux de sol là aussi
et là j'ai dit par contre que sur
celle-là matériaux de sol je c'est un
sol mais à l'horizontale puisqu'il y a
une option où il peut venir nettoyer
dans le sens du sol pour éviter de
laisser des traces comme ça vous pouvez
aller quand même vachement loin en
choisissant les matériaux que vous avez
là en plus de ça pouvez venir ajouter ce
qu'on appelle une zone restreinte
c'est-à-dire soit un mur virtuel par
exemple dire hop là et bien regardez je
viens le tourner et une fois de plus ça
vient zoomer là c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal hop là je vais mettre là je le
veux là là par exemple les bien tu ne
passeras pas donc je va un mur virtuel
donc mon aspirateur n'ira pas dans sal à
manger un bon ok tout de suite je vous
dis c'est pas le but je préfère qu'il
aille et puis je peux venir rajouter
également ensuite une zone interdite de
nettoyage ou une zone interdite pour
venir laver le sol donc comme ça en
fonction de la configuration de votre
maison vous lui direz non ça tu fais pas
ça tu fais pas là tu vas pas vous
choisissez en fait hein ça c'est plutôt
pas mal alors après hop là je clique là
je viens le supprimer je ne veux pas
mettre de mur virtuel vous pouvez
choisir également les meubles les
séquences de nettoyage on va commencer
par telle pièce ensuite on fera telle
pièce telle pièce telle pièce voyez vous
choisissez vous venez les déplacer c'est
extrêmement facile on se prend pas la
tête on choisit vraiment tout ce qu'on
veut directement ici ensuite vous avez
trois petits points en haut à droite ça
c'est truc qui nous intéresse parce que
c'est là où on va venir un petit peu
voir ce qui se passe historique de
nettoyage je vais sur mon nettoyage en
haut et là donc je vois qu'il a nettoyé
je vois qu'il a fait 37 m² il a mis 73
minutes pour le faire je vois des
petites icônes alors si vous cliquez
dessus vous voyez que là il y a eu un
obstacle là il y a eu une considère une
base en fait ce sont des meubles qui a
la pèce personne c'est pas réellement un
pèe personne alors les photos on peut
venir les activer comme ça vous saurez
exactement ce que c'est moi je l'aimis
pas j'aime pas trop qui a des photos
comme ça chez moi mais bon on peut venir
mettre les photos et là où il détact des
obstacles il vous met la chaussure voyez
c'est très très juste il y a vraiment
énormément de chaussures ici et puis
ensuite là il y a des chaises voyez donc
il reconnait les obstacles c'est quand
même cool ensuite le truc qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est le nettoyage
programmé c'est ce que je vous
recommande moi je me suis mis deux types
de nettoyage programmé lundi mardi jeudi
vendredi 9h30 nettoyage programmé je
veux qu'il me fasse tout nettoyage de
routine on peut choisir également par
pièce on peut venir personnaliser moi je
veux qu'il me fasse tout ça directement
lundi mardi jeudi vendredi à 9h30 et
puis ensuite je veux que il me fasse le
mercredi et le samedi 14h je qui nettoie
tout également j'ai rien mis le dimanche
parce que le dimanche tranquill à la
maison je veux pas d'aspirateur qui se
balade mais si vous voulez venir par
exemple et bien programmer très
facilement vous pouvez le faire vous
cliquez dessus vous choisissez le début
la répétition le les jours personnaliser
également le type de nettoyage par pièce
que vous voulez la routine en profondeur
en fait ce qui est vraiment cool c'est
que on peut vraiment aller loin au
niveau des paramètres de son aspirateur
robot paramètres des tapis point
important également là vous voyez donc
aspiration je veux que ça aspiration et
Lavache donc je ne viens pas laver mon
tapis donc ça je veux surtout pas je
peux venir les éviter à contrario si je
sais que j'ai certains tapis à très gros
poil ça peut poser éventuellement
problème bon moi je mets aspiration chez
moi il y a aucun problème d'abord
nettoyer les tapis ensuite nettoyage des
tapis renforcés et je peux mettre
également un nettoyage des tapis
intensif à vous de voir en fonction de
ce dont vous avez besoin paramètrre
également de nettoyage des sols que vous
allez avoir là nettoyer dans le sens des
sols c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure parce que comme j'ai mis que mon
parquet était dans tel sens et bien je
qu' nettoie dans tel sens pour éviter de
me laisser des traces donc c'est quand
même cool de venir le le paramétrer ici
ensuite réglage de la serpilière
intelligent ajout automatique de
détergent bien évidemment nettoy
automatique répété je l'ai mis en mode
ultime fonctionne uniquement en mode
ultime relavage automatique uniquement
en mode ultime une fois de plus j'ai la
main sur ces différents paramètres
paramètrre de mop extend basé sur lia
vous savez c'est quand il y a la
serpilère qui va se décaler alors moi je
l'ai mis avec la comme ça il se
débrouille tout seul il le fait je
laisse de façon intelligente si je veux
qu'il le fasse comme ça en standard il
vous le marque il exécutera cette
fonction une fois tous les 7 jours c'est
pas forcément ce que je veux si je le
mets très fréquent également qu'il le
fait quasiment tout le temps il vous
marque ici l'autonomie sera plus courte
donc moi je préfère le mettre sur
intelligent je lui fais confiance il
connait son métier il fait le taf et il
le fait bien alors après j'ai les
accessoires voyez il est quand même neuf
donc je suis tranquille mes accessoires
ne sont pas changés pour l'instant mais
s'il devait l'être il vous l'indiquerait
ici caméra en temps réel si vous voulez
voir ce qu'il en est moi je l'ai pas
activé fonction de laboratoire qui est
pas mal c'est l'identification des
tâches que je vous conseille de venir et
bien ici activer système d'évitement
d'obstacle avec il a que j'ai coché ici
alors il y a un truc aussi pour les
animaux domestiques si vous en avez moi
je un animal mais si vous voulez pouvez
venir également mettre un nettoyage
stratégique de la zone autour de
l'animal de compagnie bon c'est une
possibilité à vous de voir Gestion de la
batterie plus de fonction voyez comme ça
vous voyez un peu enfin bref on peut
aller quand même vachement loin ce que
je vous conseille vraiment c'est tout de
suite dans voyer volume et de venir
mettre le pack de langues en français il
y en a dans toutes les langues par
défaut il est en anglais qui vous parle
en français p venir renommer l'appareil
moi il a son petit nom l1s pro ultra hit
si vous voulez l'appeler autrement
pouvez le faire les misise à jour bien
évidemment donc vous voyez l'application
elle est super complète on peut tout
venir gérer directement ici et c'est
pour moi une des très grosses forces de
Dream me et ça c'est super important
alors bien évidemment cet aspirateur
robot dont le nom ta rallonge qui est
lez je vous montre le carton le Dream me
bot l101 pro ultra hit et bien il est
disponible dans le commerce une fois de
plus tous les liens sont en bas dans la
description c'est un robot aspirateur
qui coûte un peu moins de 1000 balles il
est à 999 € et puis il y a une offre de
lancement tout de suite à savoir que
dreamme va vous offrir une brosse
tricote supplémentaire merci k merci
dreamme si vous souhaitez donc venir
nettoyer votre maison dans les
meilleures conditions en venant vraiment
nettoyer les recoins avec un aspirateur
intelligent qui va venir nettoyer ses
sapillères qui va venir savoir quand il
y a un tapis qui va venir se balader
très facilement vous allez pouvoir
programmer également et bien penseer à
cet aspirateur robot je trouve
intéressant et une fois de plus et je le
dis je le redis et je le redis c'est
probablement des objets tech qu'il vous
faut très rapidement dans la maison pour
éviter de galérer pour enlever le souci
des tâes ménagères et moi je trouve ça
vraiment bien d'ailleurs dites-moi vous
ce que vous en pensez puis on se parle
de Dream me je vous ai présenté il y a
pas longtemps aussi un are aspirateur
robot de Dream il est juste là vous va
jeter un coup d'œil il est aussi
extrêmement
[Musique]
intéressant